hi i'm eric boss and the walking dead
series has said goodbye to rick
grimes but not in the way we expected
here we were expecting mark
to get killed off like everyone else
does but instead we got
something closer to the way itchy and
scratchy said goodbye to pucci
i have to go now my planet needs me
hey that wasn't supposed to happen those
things double-crossed me
and now we're learning about andrew
lincoln continuing to play rick in
three walking dead movies on amc what
the hell is going on
now we haven't been able to dedicate
enough resources to cover this show
weekly anymore but this is such a huge
turn of events and such an interesting
episode of television that i have to
break it down
and it's more rewarding if you haven't
seen the episode yet okay let's start
with the big question that i'm sure is
on your mind what the [ __ ] just happened
well at the end of last episode rick was
left for dead impaled on rebarb as
walkers were closing in now we've known
andrew lincoln's days on the show were
numbered and there was some interesting
symbolism with rick on the white horse
like in the book of revelation the bible
there are the four horsemen of the
apocalypse and the fourth rider rides a
pale horse
bringing with him death but rick escapes
the walkers in this episode he stays
just out of reach but still bleeds out
and slips in and out of consciousness
ultimately he clears away the walkers by
blowing them up on a bridge and he makes
his friends think he died
but he washes up a shore in front of
anne formerly jadis who radios her
contact in the helicopter and airlifts
rake out of there
i have to go now my planet needs me
so where is rick going this is where
things get a bit harder to explain this
helicopter mystery has been teased by
the show since the very first episode
when rick heard a helicopter echoing
through downtown atlanta this final
episode brought things
full circle here rick is again alone on
horseback
chase scene helicopters and if you
listen closely this episode
ended with the same music as the music
that ended the first episode it's called
space junk by wang chung
[Music]
the same way that episode signaled rick
transitioning from solitude to a broader
world of mysterious survivors
this episode is meant as a turning point
as well but a turning point to what well
the helicopter resurfaced a few times
last season rick spotted it gliding
overhead
and jadis slash and summoned it when she
briefly had negan tied down in the
junkyard this season anne has been seen
talking to this helicopter guy on the
radio cryptically referring to people as
a's
and b's we do know that anne previously
kept rick in a shipping container marked
a
and now she told the helicopter guy that
rick is a b the helicopter guy prefers
a's he tells jadis that she needs to
bring him an a
if she wants to be airlifted out of
there and a few episodes back she told
gabriel that she has been trading people
for supplies
a's seemed to be more valuable she told
gabriel all this time i thought you were
a b
and then she bops them on the head then
later ties him down and tries to attack
him with a walker the same way she
almost did with negan now there are few
possibilities for what this means the
show runner angela kang was asked if a
indicates a leader and be a follower and
she said it was a very strong
maybe but i don't see how gabriel is
more of a leader than rick the best
explanation i found is that a could
refer to an infected human who hasn't
turned yet like a strong willful
survivor type which this new community
would use for experimentation
meanwhile b could be someone they
consider to be an otherwise valuable
member of their new society
like maybe ann previously liked gabriel
and she wanted to keep him as the bee
but instead she ended up shoving a
walker at him perhaps to bite him and to
infect him
as she tried to do with a type negan and
at some point she planned to infect
rick for testing but maybe now she only
wants to recruit rick to be a
living breathing clean human to help
their community this is really the only
rationalization that makes sense to me
at this point like think about it
infected humans that haven't
turned yet are really the most rare type
of people like they exist in this unique
in-between state for a brief period of
time that wouldn't necessitate a
helicopter airlift now some are saying
this could be inspired by the
commonwealth in the walking dead comics
the commonwealth is another outside
society that the survivors come across
they have a similar class categorization
in that case it was more of a white
collar versus blue collar distinction
but all this
is what i assume the three rick movies
will explore in a very guarded interview
with the hollywood reporter scott gimple
implied this new society could pose a
threat suggesting this new arc would
pose a challenge to rick
in these movies all while the remaining
survivors on the tv show will deal with
the whispers who will be introduced
after this time jump on the show so i
think these movies would explore
rick and anne in this new strict society
perhaps one that's like quarantined
somewhere in the outside
world that's working on efforts to
research a cure
it's kind of like the story that we saw
in 28 days later in the i am legend
movie but it is clear that rick's
storyline on the tv series is
finished because this episode was filled
with rick experiencing unconscious
flashbacks to key past moments so what
did rick's visions mean
rick began this episode in his old
hospital room from the very first shot
of the series
standing over his own body as they lay
in a coma outside the birds flock in a
swarm
this actually echoes the image from the
opening moments of the first episode
this season and when he looks back they
transform into helicopters foreshadowing
his salvation at the end of the episode
later in the cabin rick finds a deer
head mounted on the wall now deers seem
to be stalking rick throughout the
series there's the one he made michonne
give to the saviors in season seven
and that goofy cgi deer at the carnival
grounds and of course the deer that
carl saw right before he got shot in
season two and this takes rick back to
his arrival in atlanta in the first
episode here he runs in two of all
people's shame
suddenly freaks back in the car with his
old cop buddy who he killed and they're
looking at this flipped car
this is actually a callback to rick's
final moments before his coma in the
very beginning when that third criminal
for the flip car
shot him goes shane asks about his
daughter
which i interpret as rick's guilty
subconscious manifesting as his old
friend helping rick accept the idea that
judith
isn't more his family than the others he
would have to leave behind
all this is to make it easier for
himself to let go shane also makes
callbacks to past rick moments referring
to the [ __ ] in the church of the red
machete
and referring to when rick bit joe in
the neck in season four later rick
reunites with herschel on the farm who
counsels him to realize it's not his
responsibility to protect
everyone forever and that he's already
given so much rick later finds himself
back in the hospital at the famous don't
open dead inside doors
or don't dead open inside doors he's
around the first episode
but here don't has been crossed out as
if to invite rick to cross over into the
world of the dead
and in this world of the dead there's a
field of bodies that rick crosses over
and it's filled with people in rick's
life both alive and dead and for some
reason sasha not his wife and son is the
one to deliver the final message coo
at the end when rick says i found them
before blowing the bridge he's talking
about his family
he found his family the people most
important to him the people he can
comfortably leave behind to look after
his fake daughter judith
as he flies back to his home planet to
discover what comes
after but my question for you guys is
are you more excited to see the
survivors face the whisperers
or rick face this new community comment
down below with your thoughts and follow
new rockstars on twitter and instagram
new rockstars and for my deeper thoughts
you can follow me on twitter and insta
avos and if you live in the la area and
you want to see me parody all these big
nerd properties come to my live comedy
show infinity fan our first show sold
out and now we're back with a new
updated show and you know don't come if
you can't take a joke about dumpsters
friday november 16th 8pm acme comedy
theater in north hollywood ticket info
in the description below
and before i go i know a lot of you want
me to go back to weekly breakdowns of
the walking dead and i appreciate your
support so much but we just cannot
afford to make walking dead videos that
often anymore
there's a lot of reasons why i don't
have time to go into all of them but
hopefully i'll check back in a few times
throughout the season to break down
the big important stuff that happens
cool subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of everything else you love
and if you need me i'll be back on my
home planet
[Music]
you